um i put together uh um
best mixtapes of all time list last year
and i had cushion oranges number one
thank you
i think it's the greatest mixtape ever i
appreciate that uh
i think i think it was like that i think
i had like rick ross's rich forever up
there
i would say um if meek mill dream chaser
juice it would be so far gone so far
gone so far gone to me is number one
because it came out before because the
thing about so far gone is like not too
far after so far gone
a lot of it ended up on like a like a
version you go by best buy i feel like
cushion oranges was like a true mixtape
because we barely just got it on dsps
like i don't know [ __ ] last year it
felt like okay but well i'll let you
handle that
but it's like like obviously you know
recently you celebrated the anniversary
of that project like um
do you like when you look at your
discography like where do you rank
that amongst like the rolling papers or
the rolling papers too or like cause you
know i feel like you have classics you
know what i mean yeah hell yeah all my
[ __ ] is crazy um
i would put cushion orange juice at
number one for sure uh that was my
ill-matic like that was my you know if
you want to listen to wiz like number
one the first project for a lot of
people
is cushion orange juice you know what
i'm saying like i had 10 mixtapes you
have like star power before you have a
lot of stuff star power i love the city
too like you know what i'm saying like i
love flight school flight school was
hard schools
you know which one had to tap my whole
body on my whole body i think that's my
high school yeah and uh bird after
rolling was crazy you know taylor alder
dice was nuts cabin fever is crazy
yo both cabins don't play with me stay
with me but you know if you want to like
be like yo all right i'm going to start
with one wiz project because that's what
a lot of people are going to start doing
at a certain point or even probably now
because i'm 10 years in the game like
where the [ __ ] do i start cushion orange
juice for sure is there an effort to try
to get the taylor all the all the dices
and the cabin fevers and all that on
dsps because now that we got cushion
orange juice because i feel like i mean
they're doing this slowly um
uh that's more like for the fans and i
love how the fans want to be on on it on
dsps but music was made so different
back then i still have the datpiff app
on my phone just to listen to people
hate that [ __ ] i was just having a
conversation with somebody well they
don't hate it i'm sorry oh my bad
that pif kp i love y'all shout outs
somebody was talking about the
functioning of it right the fact that
they can't play it and do certain things
right right right right whatever
whatever you know that's nerd [ __ ] and
that's the type of [ __ ] that i talk to
people and listen to me but i give
feedback on what they like and what they
don't like so regardless of if i want it
on dsps or not the fans the people
everybody they really really want that
[ __ ] and they love that [ __ ] but what i
was saying is music was made differently
back then um we were just grabbing songs
or samples
hell yeah throw that [ __ ] out there
there's a share file download go on tour
[ __ ] make a billion dollars and you
know they started to get pissed they
were like [ __ ] like these dudes are
making money off of like you know
whatever whatever so
they changed up how you can uh uh uh
digest that [ __ ] and really put it out
there so that's why i took a little bit
of amount of time for for my records to
clear